رونالدو ونجوم ومانشستر يونايتد حفله وداع
المنتظر في السعوديه زوجه سوداني تقدم على
خطوه مفاجاه هل ترغب في الاتصال وملاكم
بريطاني يعود الى الاضواء من بوابه
المخدرات هذه الاخبار وغيرها ان نقدمها
لكم من العربيه رياضه
كريستيانو رونالدو لاعب النصر السعودي
دعوه لنجوم مانشستر يونايتد الانجليزيه
للقدومي الى السعوديه
الى السعوديه
قد غادر جميع مجموعات الواتساب الخاصه
بلاعبي الشياطين الحمر الا انه مازال على
تواصل شخصي مع هرمجون فرنانديز وكريسميرو
حتى انه دعاهم لبيته الجديد في لشبونه
وللحضور الى السعوديه لمشاهدته يلعب في
صفوف الاصفر العاصمي
في حديثه طريفه انشغلت بها وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي خلال الساعات الماضيه فضح كتاب
جديد جريمه سرقه نفذها الدولي الانجليزيه
ووفق كتابا كيف لا اكون قويه تبين ان
لاعبه مانشستر يونايتد السابق اخذ خصه
ملعقه من على طاوله كتفكار اثناء اجتماعي
مع بلادي بوتر رئيس الروسي في الاكراملين
اثناء فعاليات مونديال 2018 الذي يقيم في
روسيا
والان الى جوانا سانس زوجه اللاعب
البرازيلي داني الفيس التي تمر بفتره صعبه
في خلال اسبوع واحد توفيت والدتها وتتم
محاكمه زوجها بتهمه الاغتصاب
القليله الماضيه بخطوه غريبه مفاجاه او حد
فيها برقبتها في الانفصال عن لاعب برشلونه
السابق حيثما حيث العارضه الاسبانيه في
حسابها على الانستغرام جميع الصور التي
تجمعها باللاعب البرازيلي حتى صور زفاف
وكتبت قلبي هل يمكنك التحمل هذا القدر من
الالم البعض ظننا في تعليقها انها تساند
زوجها ليظهره ليظهره فيما بعد انها تعبر
عن امامها من كل ما تمر به
الختام مع الصور التي تم تداولها عبر
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي التي تظهر كلب
روك الملاكم البريطانيه المحترف في فئه
الوزن المتوسط وهو يتعاطى مسحوقا ابيضا في
حفله اقامها في منزله مع اصدقائه وكيلوا
بطل الاتحاد الدولي للملاكمه في فئه الوزن
المتوسط لعام 2014
[موسيقى]